spannend das kann ich ihnen jetzt schon
versprechen denn wir haben einen putin
befürworter in putin-kritiker hier im
studio eingeladen und freuen uns auf den
austausch der argumente ganz herzlich
willkommen schon mal an sie beide und
die erste frage an herrn schreier sie
sind buchautor und journalist buchautor
vor allem wir sind die guten ansichten
eines putin verstoß oder wie uns die
medien manipulieren was genau sind die
kernargumente der putin befürworte warum
ist putin ein guter in anführungsstriche
so würde ich es nicht formulieren also
dieser begriff putin verstehen wie wir
in dem titel verwendet haben ist
ironisch gemeinte also wir sind die
guten ist ist ja auch eine
hintergründige ironie wir wollen einfach
zeigen dass es aus unserer sicht meint
co autor mathias bröckers und ist jetzt
mit uns gemeint dass wir einfach ein
problem damit haben wenn man sagt wir
der westen sind die guten und die
anderen müssen sich uns anpassen und wir
wollen auch sozusagen in dieser sendung
versuchen dieses simple gut schlecht
denken ein wenig aufzulösen aber wir
wollen es natürlich auch aufgreifen
reitschuster boris reitschuster sie sind
russland korrespondent des focus aber
leben in berlin das müssen sie erklären
ich bin im exil ich habe immer wieder
todesdrohungen bekommen und auch
angriffe man hat mir gesagt mit meinem
buch habe ich mein todesurteil
unterzeichnet und deswegen musste ich
aus sicherheitsgründen aus moskau zurück
ihr buch ist putins demokratur ein
russland kritisches buch warum protein
kritisch nicht russland krieg ich bin
großer russlandfreundlich das ist ja
noch lang in russland 15 jahre meine
kinder sprechen russisch meine frau ist
wo sonst auch dolmetscher genau kennen
russland aus den 90er jahren als aus als
moskauer bürgern da haben wir auch im
film als russe ist meine zweite heimat
schön warum verstehen sie sich so
schlecht mit putin ich denke was putin
tut ist ganz verheerend für russland ich
habe das jeden tag erlebt meine
verwandten erleben ist heute noch jeden
tag und es ist ein unrechtsstaat wo man
jeden tag diesem unrecht ausgeliefert
ist und es ist einfach eine schreckliche
entwicklungen unter pudel ist das immer
schlechter warum ist das ein
unrechtsstaat weil die gesetze nicht
gelten weil die ständig gebrochen werden
putin bricht die gesetze inzwischen auch
das völkerrecht und im inland wird das
gesetz auch ständig gebrochen ich könnte
ihn sehr sehr lange erzählen was erlebt
habe was meine freunde erleben was man
eine verwandte erleben und das ist ein
sehr schwieriges leben wenn man damit
immer kämpfen der schweiz starke
argumente wie es ihre position ich würde
dem gar nicht diametral widersprechen
ich würde einfach nur in den fokus
setzen wollen dass wie ich eingangs
schon meinte dass es in der westlichen
berichterstattung über den ukraine
konflikt über putin ist ja ganz stark
dieser sucht text dass wir eigentlich
auf der richtigen seite stehen wir der
westen und wir also für das gute und für
die werte stehen und allein putin ist
jetzt der böse der sozusagen uns diesen
westlichen werten widerspricht und das
darin steckt für mich eine gewisse
überheblichkeit eine gewisse arroganz
weil das so aus meiner sicht nicht
stimmt aber wenn sie den westen jetzt
sozusagen kritisch sehen
heißt das ja nicht automatisch dass ihr
den putin gut sehen müssen nein
natürlich nicht genau und so haben wir
das eigentlich auch in unserem buch
gehalten würden jetzt keine putin
verehrer in diesem buch sondern wir
benennen auch dass es große defizite in
der russischen gesellschaft gibt und das
russische politik jetzt nicht
verehrungswürdig ist also alles andere
als das was wir halt bemängeln ist
dieser moralische rigorismus jetzt zu
sagen wir wissen wie es geht und wir
dürfen unsere geopolitischen ziele also
durchsetzen aber andere mächte dürfen
das nicht verstört sie denn dafür ein ja
oder nein aber wir hier was heißt wird
irgendwie durchsetzen putin ist
einmarschiert ist dort gewalt er ist mit
einem krieg auf das nachbarland gekommen
und das machen wir doch im westen
wirklich nicht also da setzt man zwei
dinge gleich denke ich die wirklich doch
jetzt nichts miteinander zu tun haben
die nicht vergleichbar sind wir sind
noch kein engagierter bei uns gleich ein
haken also da würde ich natürlich genau
widersprechen denn weder westen machen
das natürlich beinahe schon regelmäßig
also wenn sie an den irak krieg denken
2003 an den einsatz in libyen 2011 und
so weiter es gibt zahlreiche beispiele
dafür dass nicht annektiert worden da
sich einfach merken heimisches eben
wieder weg in unter bruch des
völkerrechts sehr aggressiv vorgeht und
allein das führt aus meiner sicht diese
moralischen anspruch schon auch ad
absurdum in gewisser weise wo ist der
westen überheblich sie sagten das vorhin
der westen sei auf die überheblich ja es
gibt aus meiner sicht so diese denkweise
dass ja die eigene position eigentlich
nicht hinterfragt wird also dass die
position des westens per se die richtige
ist und das eigentlich auch das
westliche system das system ist das
logischerweise überall auf der welt sich
ausbreiten kann und auch muss weil es
das etliche system ist und natürlich
gibt es andere großmächte auf der welt
es gibt china es gibt russland es gibt
die bric staaten china russland indien
brasilien die eine ganz große welt macht
sie natürlich eine eigene politik
verfolgen die oft auch diametral im
westen entgegengesetzten das muss man
sehen dass das mächte sind die auch
fairerweise sie mal auf augenhöhe
behandelt muss er als schlosser direkt
darauf und dann ihre ich sehe das ganz
anders weil hier wird ein krieg
ausgelöst in europa man hat ein anderes
land annektiert man hat die ganz in
ordnung die friedensordnung auf die füße
gestellt das ist wie wenn auf der straße
wenn sie sehen eine frau wird überfallen
und dann muss man etwas tun und man kann
nicht sagen ja aber andere überfallen
auch frauen andere machen das auch und
ich finde wir sollten uns darauf
konzentrieren dass irgendwann irgendwo
auch andere unrecht gemacht haben das
ist keine rechtfertigung okay da würde
ich gerne ein haken und ich möchte ihnen
zustimmen dass natürlich die
angliederung der krim natürlich
rechtswidrig gewesen es in gewisser
weise hat russland hat er klar das
völkerrecht gebrochen aber das war eben
nicht der anfang des konfliktes unter
der konflikt begann die zuspitzung des
konfliktes begann eigentlich ende
februar mit dem gewaltsamen machtwechsel
in kiew